seven patients blood pressures have been
measured after having been given a new
drug for three months they had blood
pressure increases of and they give us
seven data points right here who knows
when it's in some blood pressure units
construct a 95% confidence interval for
the true the true expected blood
pressure increase for all patients in a
population so there's some population
distribution here it's a reasonable
assumption to think that it is normal
it's a biological process so if you gave
this drug to every person who has ever
lived and you just that will result in
some mean increase mean increase in
blood pressure or who knows maybe it's
an actual decrease and there's also
going to be some standard deviation here
there's going to be some standard
deviation here it is a normal
distribution and the reason why it's
reasonable to assume that it's a normal
distribution is because it's a
biological process it's going to be the
sum of many thousands and millions of
random events and things that are sums
of many millions and thousands of random
events tend to be normal distribution so
this is a population distribution this
is the population distribution and we
don't know anything really about it
outside of the sample that we have here
now what we can do is and just tends to
be a good thing to do when you do have a
sample let's just figure out everything
that you can figure out about that
sample from the get-go so we have our
seven data points and you can add them
up and divide by seven and get your
sample mean so our sample mean our
sample mean here is two point three four
and then you can also calculate your
sample standard deviation find the
squared distance from each of these
points to your sample mean add them up
divide by n minus one because it's a
sample then take the square root and you
get your sample standard deviation I did
this ahead of time just to save time
sample standard deviation is 1.04 and
when you don't know anything about the
population distribution the thing that
we've been doing from the get-go is
estimating is estimating that character
with our sample standard deviation so
we've been estimating the true standard
deviation of the population with our
with our sample standard
with our sample standard deviation now
in this problem this exact problem we're
going to run into a problem we're
estimating our standard deviation with
an N of only 7 so this is probably going
to be a not so good estimate not so good
because because because let me just
write because n is n is small in general
this is considered a bad estimate if n
is less than 30 above 30 you're dealing
in the realm of pretty good estimates
and so the whole focus of this video is
when we think about the sampling
distribution which is what is what we're
going to use to generate our interval
instead of assuming that the sampling
distribution is normal like we did in
the in many other videos using the
central limit theorem and all of that
we're going to have a we're going to
tweak the sampling distribution we're
not going to assume it's a normal
distribution because this is a bad
estimate we're going to assume that it
is something called a T distribution and
the T distribution is essentially the
best way to think about it it's almost
engineered it's almost engineered so it
gives a better estimate of your
confidence intervals and all of that
when you do have a small sample size and
it looks very similar to a normal
distribution it looks very similar to a
normal distribution it has some mean so
this is your mean of your sampling
distribution still but it also has
fatter tails it has fatter fatter tails
and the way I think about why it has
fatter tails is when you assume when you
make an assumption that this is the
standard deviation for well let me let
me go let me take one more step so
normally what we do is we find the
estimate of the true standard deviation
and then we say that the standard
deviation of the sampling distribution
the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution is equal to the true
standard deviation of our population
divided by the square root of N in this
case n is equal to seven and then we say
okay we never know the true standard or
we seldom know sometimes you do know we
seldom know the true standard deviation
so if we don't know that the best thing
we can put in there
is our sample standard deviation so the
best thing we can put in there is our
sample standard deviation and this this
right here this is the whole reason why
we even call it well we don't say that
this is just a 95 probability interval
this is a whole reason we call it a
confidence interval because we're we're
making some assumptions here this thing
is going to change from sample to sample
and in particular this is going to be a
particularly bad estimate when we have a
small sample size a size less than 30 so
when you are estimating the standard
deviation where you don't know it you're
estimating it with your sample standard
deviation and your sample size is small
and you're going to use this to estimate
your standard deviation of your sampling
distribution you don't assume your
sampling distribution is a normal
distribution
you assume it has fat or tails and it
has fatter tails because you're
essentially under estimating you're
under estimating the standard deviation
over here anyway with all of that said
let's just actually go through this
problem so we need to think about a 95%
confidence interval around this mean
right over here so a 95% confidence
interval if you if this was a normal
distribution you would just look it up
in a Z table but it's not this is a T
distribution this is a T distribution
we're looking for a 95% confidence
interval so some some interval around
the mean that encapsulates 95% of the
area for T distribution you use a T
table and I have a t-table ahead of time
right over here and what you want to do
is use the two-sided you want to use the
two-sided row for what we're doing right
over here and the best way to think
about is that we're symmetric
we're symmetric around the mean this is
a what we then that's why they call it
two-sided it would be one side if it was
kind of a cumulative percentage up to
some critical threshold but in this case
it's two-sided we're symmetric or
another way to think about is we're
excluding the two sides so we want the
ninety-five percent in the middle and
this is a sampling distribution this is
a sampling distribution sampling
distribution of the sample mean for n is
equal to seven and I won't go into the
details here
when n is equal to seven you have six
degrees of freedom or n minus 1 and
minus one and the way that tea tables
are set up you go and find the degrees
of freedom so you don't go to the end
you go to the N minus 1 so you go to the
6 right here so if you want to
encapsulate 95% of this right over here
and you want and you have an N of 6 you
have to go to point 4 4 7 standard
deviations in each direction and this T
stable this tea table assumes that you
are approximating that standard
deviation using your sample standard
deviation so it's another way to think
of it you have to go to point four for
seven of these approximated standard
deviations so let me need to go right
here so you have to go to point four
four seven this distance right here is
two point four four seven times times
this approximated times this
approximated standard deviation this
approximated standard deviation and
sometimes you'll see this in some
statistics book this thing right here
this exact number is shown like this
they put a little hat on top of the
standard deviation to show that it has
been approximated using the sample
standard deviation so we'll put a little
hat over here because frankly this is
the only thing that we can calculate so
this is how far you have to go in each
direction now we know what this value is
we know what the sample distribution is
so let's get our calculator out let's
get our calculator out so let me let me
get our calculator so we know our sample
standard deviation is one point zero
four one point zero four and we want to
divide that by the square root of seven
divided by the square root of seven so
we get point three nine so we get point
three nine so this right here this right
here this right here is zero point three
nine and so if we want to find the
distance around this this population
mean that encapsulates 95 percent of the
population or of the sampling
distribution we have to multiply 0.39
times two point four four seven so let's
do that
so x times two point four four seven is
equal to 0.96 so this is equal to so
this distance right here so this
distance right here is 0.96 and then
this distance right here is 0.96 so if
you take a random sample and that's
exactly what we did when we when we
found these these seven samples when we
took these seven samples and took their
mean that mean can be viewed as a random
sample from the sampling distribution
and so the probability and so we can
view it we could say that there's a 95%
chance 95% chance and we actually
actually caveat everything with a
confident because we're doing all of
these estimations here so it's not a
true precise a 95% chance we're just
confident that there's a 95% chance that
our random population a random sampling
mean right here so that 2.3 for which we
can kind of use we just pick that 2.3
for from this this this distribution
right here so there's a 95% chance that
2.34 is within is within point nine six
zero point nine six of the true sampling
distribution mean which we know is also
the same thing as the population mean of
so I'll just say with it
of the population mean or we can just
rearrange the sentence and say that
there is a 95% chance 95% chance that
the mean the true mean which is the same
thing as the sampling distribution mean
is within is within 0.96 of our sample
mean of two point three four so at the
low end so if you go to point three six
minus if you go to point three four two
point three four minus 0.9 six that's
the low end of our confidence interval
one point three eight and the high end
of our confidence interval two point
three four plus point nine six is equal
to three point
three so we our 95% confidence interval
is from one point three eight to three
point three